les travaux de prolongement du rer e
avance l'un des gros chantiers de ce
projet c'est la création de cette
troisième voie le but du travaux est de
créer une voie supplémentaire entre les
garder paul mézières et de man station
soit environ 3 km cette voie permettra
de fluidifier le trafic ferroviaire et
apportera de la robustesse et améliorer
la régularité de l'exploitation
ferroviaire en cas de retard d'un train
d'une panne ou d'une plus faible vitesse
sur l'une des deux voies
un dépassement pourra être possible sur
cette troisième voie et pour la créer et
conserver un chemin pour piétons et
cyclistes
il a fallu construire sur la scène nous
sommes ici au droit du futur chemin du
halage
donc dans le cas de travaux nous avons
élargi de 4 m la berge avec un mur de
soutènement palplanches pour permettre
de maintenir le chemin de halage au
public à l'issue de nos travaux jusqu'à
100 personnes travaillent
quotidiennement sur le chantier de cette
troisième voie aujourd'hui on est sur
les travaux de génie civil utilisation
en cours
nous commençons aussi la pose des
équipements ferroviaires notamment les
supports caténaire la poste de travail
voient commenceront au mois de mars de
cette année les travaux sont prévus
jusque août 2023 avec la mise hors
service
avec de tels travaux il a fallu penser à
la faune et la flore les plantes rares
présentes sur le site ont été replantés
ailleurs et un espace pour favoriser la
reproduction des poissons va être
aménagé